turkey has pulled out of an
international accord designed to protect
women from domestic violence and promote
equality
the council of europe accord is known as
the istanbul convention
turkey was the first signatory in 2011.
dozens of nations and the eu followed
suit
government officials say domestic law
rather than outside fixes
should deal with women's rights and
conservatives in turkey
say the agreement threatens family
values a women's right group recorded at
least
300 femicides in the country last year
well for more unless i'm joined by al
turkey correspondent yulia han who's at
a protest rally in
istanbul julia tell us what you're
hearing from the women who are there
today
well there's a lot of anger and outrage
here on the streets
in istanbul today women are protesting
against president erdogan's decision to
withdraw
from the so-called istanbul convention a
landmark international treaty designed
to protect women from gender-based
violence and when this news broke
today earlier in the morning that prison
aired on by decree decided to annul the
ratification of this treaty
women's rights groups started to
organize on social media calling for
nationwide protests
so this is one of them there you can see
right behind me
hundreds if not thousands of women came
here to gather and to tell the
government that they are
against this decision especially as they
say
at a time when we're seeing skyrocketing
rates of gender-based violence here in
turkey
domestic violence is on the rise
according to rights groups and so
as you mentioned is the number of
femicides
well i mean conservatives say that the
agreement which is designed to protect
women
in fact threatens family values i mean
is that the official reason is that
president
erdogan's reason why has turkey
withdrawn from this accord
well in fact when turkey signed the
istanbul convention here in istanbul in
2011 it was seen as
a breakthrough in terms of gender
equality but the discussion here the
debate has
completely changed last year senior
politicians and president erdogan's
conservative islamist rooted
akp started to argue that this
convention
encourages as they said immoral
lifestyles like
homosexuality they were met with massive
protests by
women but now it seems president erdogan
that's what observers say bowed into the
pressure coming from heartliners in his
ruling coalition so he is trying
to re-energize the conservative
voter-based
emit voter base amid an economic
downturn so that's what observers say
that
has domestic reasons what we're seeing
here right now
are the government not worried about
unrest that this decision
could provoke
well this uh these protests are
definitely not going
to go away i mean we're expecting more
of them i guess in the next days and
weeks to come
because even conservative women told me
that they're in favor of this istanbul
convention so there must be some kind of
political rationale here for president
erdogan to come up
with this decision at this time
all right julia thank you turkey
correspondent yulia han in istanbul
you